- Yaël Braun-Pivet: L'ordre du
jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement.
La première question va être posée
par madame Michèle Tabarot pour le
groupe Les Républicains.
- Michèle Tabarot: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
"O, France, voici venu le jour où
il te faut rendre des comptes".
Ces paroles sont issues du
troisième couplet de l'hymne
national algérien.
Aujourd'hui, ce couplet est remis
à l'ordre du jour.
Quel camouflet, pour le président
Macron!
Combien d'actes de repentance
inutiles?
Combien de vexations inutiles
après le recul sur les visas et
l'ingérence dans nos élections?
Ce pouvoir algérien vit sur une
rente mémorielle depuis 60 ans.
Vous souhaitez normaliser nos
relations avec ce pays mais nous
n'avons récolté que du mépris, au
travers d'un sentiment
antifrançais exacerbé.
Nous nous sommes tournés vers
l'Algérie au détriment de nos
alliés marocains.
La décision du pouvoir algérien
n'a rien d'innocent.
Ce n'est pas un acte à
contretemps, comme tente de le
justifier votre ministre des
Affaires étrangères.
C'est un geste calculé, qui
désigne la France comme l'ennemi.
Un hymne national qui désigne un
pays comme un ennemi, c'est
inacceptable.
Allez-vous avoir une réaction à la
hauteur de notre indignation?
Nous demandons l'abrogation de
l'accord de 1968, qui facilite
l'immigration algérienne en
France.
Allez-vous reprendre le contrôle
et donner à notre pays le respect
qu'il mérite?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Chrysoula Zacharopoulou.
- Chrysoula Zacharopoulou: Merci.
Madame la députée, je vous prie
d'abord d'excuser la ministre qui
est actuellement en déplacement.
La question que vous posez est
très sensible.
Elle concerne l'hymne national
d'un pays étranger et évoque une
histoire douloureuse.
Le couplet en question a toujours
fait partie de l'hymne national
algérien, composé en 1956.
Il n'a pas été ajouté.
Le décret du 21 mai 2023 formalise
simplement la pratique selon
laquelle l'hymne national algérien
est désormais chanté dans son
intégralité.
Comme l'a dit la ministre des
Affaires étrangères, cette
décision semble à contretemps.
Notre ambition commune, avec
l'Algérie et les Algériens, c'est
de regarder notre histoire en
face.
Cette histoire, il ne s'agit pas
de l'escamoter.
Nous devons nous projeter vers
l'avenir.
Nous travaillons avec nos
partenaires algériens, pour
approfondir nos relations, pour un
partenariat renouvelé entre la
France et l'Algérie.
C'est un choix exigeant.
Mais il est dans l'intérêt de la
France de le suivre, comme dans
celui de l'Algérie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, madame la ministre.
Chahut
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Jean-Victor Castor.
- Jean-Victor Castor: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Tout d'abord, permettez-moi de
saluer l'annonce de l'entrée au
Panthéon du résistant communiste
Missak Manouchian, ainsi que de
son épouse.
Applaudissements
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Transition écologique.
En Guyane, sur 8,5 millions
d'hectares, vous avez décidé que
95% du foncier relèvent de
l'unique responsabilité de l'Etat.
Cela concerne les parcs nationaux,
le conservatoire du littoral.
Vous avez décidé que moins de 5%
de notre territoire peut
aujourd'hui être aménageable.
Pourtant, l'urgence
socio-économique est évidente et
elle appelle la construction de
logements et d'équipement public.
L'INSEE annonce un doublement de
la population guyanaise d'ici
2050.
Il faut donc bâtir ce pays de
Guyane.
La mise sous cloche, au nom d'une
vision parisienne de la protection
de l'environnement, est totalement
irresponsable.
Cela conduit à la pollution des
sols et des rivières, à la
multiplication des squats.
L'empilement de mesures drastiques
se traduit par une insécurité
administrative qui empêche le
développement des logements et
constitue le terreau d'une crise
sociale.
Il y a un équilibre à trouver
entre la protection de
l'environnement et le
développement.
Mais cela ne peut pas être décrété
depuis Paris.
Pour aménager son territoire, la
Guyane attend le transfert du
foncier aux acteurs locaux.
Que répondez-vous?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Bérangère Couillard.
- Bérangère Couillard: La
biodiversité en Guyane, elle est
extraordinaire.
Plus de 5000 espèces de plantes,
540 espèces d'oiseaux.
Elle est aujourd'hui encore
préservée.
La Guyane française dispose d'un
réseau conséquent d'espaces
protégés qui couvre plus de la
moitié de sa superficie totale.
Cela contribue à notre réseau
d'espaces protégés.
Le gouvernement est attentif à
concilier la protection de la
biodiversité avec les impératifs
de développement.
C'est l'essence même de notre
politique de ne pas mettre sous
cloche, comme vous l'avez dit.
Réduire la protection de la
biodiversité à une contrainte,
c'est un raccourci que je déplore.
La nature est aussi une chance.
Elle apporte beaucoup aux
communautés locales.
Par exemple, le parc amazonien de
Guyane, par sa lutte contre
l'orpaillage illégal, aide à la
santé des populations locales.
Vous connaissez les taux de
mercure dans les cours d'eau.
Il faut lutter contre la
déforestation illégale pour se
préoccuper de la santé des
habitants de Guyane.
Mais vous avez raison, il faut
s'adapter.
Il y a des équilibres à trouver.
Nous devons tenir compte des
spécificités locales.
Cela est permis par l'article 73
de la Constitution.
Nous allons proposer des
simplifications pour aider à
l'aménagement de la Guyane.
Je vous rassure donc, monsieur le
député, sur notre souci de
réconcilier protection de
l'environnement et développement
de l'activité en Guyane.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Marie Pochon.
- Marie Pochon: Ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre des
Collectivités territoriales.
"La campagne, c'est bien pour
penser à rien".
Clin d'oeil à Wolinski.
C'est une citation qui semble vous
avoir inspiré pour votre plan
France Ruralités.
Les habitants des territoires
ruraux ont deux ans d'espérance de
vie en moins que leurs
compatriotes urbains.
56% des maires ruraux ne veulent
pas se représenter en 2026.
Cette liste ne répond pas aux
besoins de décentralisation.
Nous avons besoin d'une politique
d'installations massives en
agriculture.
Nous avons besoin de solutions
face aux violences faites aux
femmes dans les ruralités.
Vous avez refusé de réguler
l'installation des médecins.
Demain, vous avez refusé de
réguler la location des meublés
touristiques.
Nous avons besoin d'un leadership
que vous n'exercez pas, d'une
volonté que vous n'avez pas.
C'est pourtant dans ces
territoires que se joue notre
avenir.
Les doléances des gilets jaunes
portaient de la colère mais aussi
des espoirs.
Si vous prenez un jour le temps de
les lire, vous trouverez des
milliers d'aspirations à des
actions de solidarité pour pallier
les défaillances de l'Etat.
Quand allez-vous enfin changer de
paradigme et reconnaître les
campagnes comme les actrices de la
transition?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Dominique Faure, ministre
déléguée chargée des Collectivités
territoriales et de la Ruralité.
- Dominique Faure: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée, vous avez
raison.
Les territoires ruraux attendent
beaucoup de nous.
Ce n'est pas moi qui vous dirai le
contraire, après 66 visites dans
les territoires.
En juin dernier, la Première
ministre a annoncé le plan France
Ruralités.
Une ribambelle de mesures qui
mettent la transition écologique
au coeur de nos territoires
ruraux.
C'est le fruit d'un travail que
nous poursuivons depuis neuf mois.
Nous souhaitons soutenir davantage
nos maires ruraux.
Nous voulons les aider dans les
projets qu'ils veulent porter.
Ce sont des financements
d'ingénierie pour pouvoir délivrer
plus de services à nos habitants
des ruralités.
Ensuite, vous nous interpellez sur
le sujet de la transition
écologique.
C'est tout simplement 90% de nos
forêts qui sont en territoires
ruraux, donc la dotation
biodiversité qui était à 40
millions, nous allons la passer à
plus de 100 millions d'euros en
faveur de nos communes des
ruralités.
Nous allons continuer à travailler
autour de la santé, autour des
mobilités et autour de la lutte
contre les logements vacants.
Nous voulons pérenniser nos zones
de vitalisation rurales afin de
faciliter l'accès aux médecins et
aux commerces de proximité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, madame la ministre.
La parole est à monsieur Thomas
Rudigoz pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Thomas Rudigoz: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur, ce week-end, dans la
vallée de la Maurienne, les
Soulèvements de la Terre ont une
nouvelle fois organisé une
manifestation interdite.
Des gendarmes ont été blessés.
Je salue leur professionnalisme,
face à des personnes qui
cherchaient la confrontation.
Applaudissements
La raison de ces violences: la
construction d'une ligne
ferroviaire entre Lyon et Turin.
Les mêmes qui reprochent au
gouvernement une prétendue
inaction climatique s'opposent à
une ligne ferroviaire qui
permettra de basculer des poids
lourds vers le rail.
Elle permettra d'améliorer la
qualité de l'air des vallées
alpines et elle nous permettra de
répondre à nos impératifs
climatiques.
Il y a donc une manipulation de
l'opinion contre ce projet
essentiel pour les Alpes et ses
habitants.
Les habitants de la région
Rhône-Alpes souffrent de pollution
et certains inventent une fable
sur de l'eau qui serait aspirée
par le tunnel.
Certains tergiversent autour d'une
voie du 19e siècle qui est
complètement inadaptée.
Il faut sortir de vos dogmes et il
faut écouter ceux de votre camp
qui soutiennent le Lyon-Turin,
comme les socialistes et les
communistes.
Je tiens à remercier le ministre
des Transports pour son soutien
déterminé et qui vient d'annoncer
le financement des voies d'accès
au tunnel.
La confrontation avec les forces
de l'ordre est devenue la norme,
entretenue par des groupuscules
comme les Soulèvements de la
Terre.
La République ne peut le tolérer.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur, quelles mesures
comptez-vous prendre pour empêcher
ce mouvement radical de frapper
encore?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Gérald Darmanin,
ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin: Monsieur le
député, j'ai également une pensée
pour les 13 militaires de la
gendarmerie qui ont été blessés ce
week-end.
Aucune cause ne justifie que l'on
blesse des policiers ou des
gendarmes.
Applaudissements
Je voudrais rappeler que cette
manifestation était interdite.
Cela a été confirmé à deux
reprises par la justice de notre
pays.
Malgré cela, entre 2000 et 3000
personnes, dont malheureusement
des élus de la République,
l'interdiction a été bravée.
Le travail fait par les policiers
les gendarmes a permis 350
contrôles d'armes et d'armes de
poing qui auraient pu blesser ou
tuer les policiers et les
gendarmes.
Grâce au travail de nos services
de renseignements, une centaine
d'éléments radicaux venus d'Italie
ont pu être bloqués à la
frontière.
Malgré cela, malheureusement, il y
a eu deux jours d'affrontements,
une autoroute occupée et de
nombreux personnels des services
publics qui ont fait face à la
haine et la violence.
A la demande du président de la
République, demain matin, je
présenterai au Conseil des
ministres le décret de dissolution
des Soulèvements de la Terre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur Jérôme
Buisson pour le Rassemblement
National.
- Jérôme Buisson: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre de
l'Education nationale.
Le 16 mai dernier, à Nice, un
groupe de 10 élèves s'est réuni
sous le préau de son école pour
prier.
Des faits intolérables.
Plus de 1000 signalements
d'atteinte à la laïcité dans nos
établissements ont été enregistrés
au cours des mois d'avril et de
mai.
Il est clair que notre école fait
face à une nouvelle offensive de
l'islam radical.
Une offensive face à laquelle vous
restez passifs.
Vous vous défaussez sur les chefs
d'établissement et vous les
laissez apprécier ou non le
caractère religieux des vêtements
portés par les élèves, comme les
abayas.
Il n'y a pas de soutien de la
hiérarchie face à des adolescents
galvanisés.
Souvenez-vous du courage du
proviseur du collège de Creil,
quand il a interdit aux élèves de
se voiler.
Vous recréez les conditions qui
ont conduit au meurtre de Samuel
Paty.
Il faut être courageux aujourd'hui
pour être professeur de collège ou
de lycée.
Monsieur le ministre, vous
demandez aux chefs
d'établissements et aux
professeurs de faire preuve du
courage que vous n'avez pas.
Pourtant, des solutions existent.
Nous avions proposé de rendre
obligatoire le port de l'uniforme
à l'école mais vous avez rejeté
cette idée.
Je vous propose, avec ma
proposition de loi, de définir par
décret une liste des signes et
tenues considérés comme marquant
une appartenance à une confession
religieuse.
Vous ne pouvez plus laisser des
chefs d'établissement seuls face à
une religion politique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Pap Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député, le cadre
juridique est clair.
C'est celui de la loi de 2004.
Il a une portée générale.
Il interdit donc toute tenue ou
tout signe de nature religieuse
dans les écoles et les
établissements scolaires.
Cette loi doit être absolument
respectée.
Il en va de même pour les
manifestations comme celle que
vous venez d'évoquer.
Il est clair que toute
manifestation prosélyte est à
proscrire absolument.
Le maire de Nice comme moi-même
sommes tombés d'accord pour
condamner ce qui s'est passé et
former les agents de l'Education
nationale, ainsi que ceux du
périscolaire, pour que de tels
événements ne se reproduisent pas
à partir de la rentrée.
Du côté de l'abaya, notre position
est très claire.
Elle a été précisée par une
circulaire du mois de novembre
dernier.
Toutes tenues manifestant une
intention religieuse sont
proscrites dans les écoles et les
enceintes scolaires.
Cela doit être respecté.
D'un point de vue juridique,
cependant, la notion d'abaya n'a
pas de définition juridique.
Nous serions dans l'incapacité
auprès du juge de définir
précisément ce que c'est.
La seule voie possible est donc la
fermeté dans les principes et le
soutien aux équipes pédagogiques,
ainsi que l'aide des équipes des
valeurs de la République, qui se
déplacent dans les lycées
concernés.
Ma position est claire: fermeté
dans les principes et aide aux
équipes, ainsi que des formations.
Nous avons formé 300.000
professeurs à ce jour.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Anne-Laure
Babault pour le groupe Démocrates.
- Anne-Laure Babault: Ma question
s'adresse à Olivier Klein.
Ce vendredi soir, heureusement, il
n'y a pas eu de morts.
Mais le traumatisme est profond.
La terre a fortement tremblé dans
la Charente-Maritime.
Ce sont des vies qui ont vacillé.
Environ 250 maisons inhabitables,
500 personnes directement
impactées.
Sur place, le lendemain, j'ai
rencontré des habitants choqués et
inquiets.
Où, quand, comment?
Où seront-ils relogés?
Quand seront-ils indemnisés?
Comment seront-ils accompagnés?
Il est essentiel que nous prenions
tous la mesure de cette
catastrophe, afin d' agir au plus
vite.
Gérald Darmanin a annoncé une
procédure accélérée de
reconnaissance de catastrophe
naturelle.
Vous vous êtes rendus hier, avec
Christophe Béchu, sur les communes
les plus sinistrées.
Au nom des parlementaires
concernés, je vous remercie.
Nous saluons nos pompiers et nos
gendarmes qui sont une nouvelle
fois exemplaires.
Nous saluons l'élan de solidarité
qui a été mis en place.
Nous remercions aussi les maires,
les élus et les employés communaux
qui font un travail exceptionnel
pour répondre à la détresse des
habitants.
Ils ont besoin de la solidarité
nationale.
Aujourd'hui et demain, car nous
rentrons dans une période de temps
long.
Les maisons doivent être
sécurisées.
Les personnes doivent être
relogées à long terme.
Pouvez-vous nous détailler les
actions que l'Etat va mettre en
place?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Klein, ministre délégué
chargé de la Ville et du Logement.
- Olivier Klein: Merci, madame la
députée.
Je vous remercie de votre question
et je salue à travers vous
l'ensemble des parlementaires de
la Charente-Maritime que nous
avons rencontrés hier avec
Christophe Béchu.
Je souhaite redire, au nom de
l'ensemble du gouvernement, toute
notre solidarité auprès des
victimes sinistrées par ce séisme
aussi violent qu'inattendu.
Nous sommes allés hier sur place
pour saluer l'ensemble des équipes
de secours.
La gendarmerie est toujours
présente sur le site pour
sécuriser les habitations qui ont
été laissées vides et répondre aux
inquiétudes légitimes des
populations qui ont dû laisser
vide leur logement.
En ce qui concerne les mesures qui
seront prises, le ministre de
l'Intérieur a annoncé la mise en
oeuvre rapide de l'état de
catastrophe naturelle.
Les premiers cas seront examinés
par la commission du 29 juin.
En attendant, nous allons mettre
en oeuvre un certain nombre de
mesures, notamment la mise en
place de la dotation de solidarité
en faveur de l'équipement des
collectivités touchées par un
événement climatique grave.
Un certain nombre de subventions
vont être versées aux
collectivités locales.
Ensuite, nous allons mettre en
place le fonds d'urgence au
relogement qui, là aussi, pourra
venir en complément des
assurances.
Cet état de catastrophe doit être
compris par le milieu des
assurances.
Nous allons travailler avec eux et
avec l'ensemble des préfectures
sur ce cas si grave et
particulier.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Jean-François Coulomme
pour La France Insoumise.
- Jean-François Coulomme: Monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur,
creuser plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres sous les massifs
alpins, siphonner chaque année
plus d'un million de mètres cubes
d'eau potable dans les nappes
phréatiques, ravager des hectares
de terres agricoles, recracher sur
les terres des milliers de mètres
cubes de béton, c'est un
titanesque ravage.
Vous nous promettez une
infrastructure espérée pour 2048.
Le coût total des travaux est de
40 millions d'euros.
Enfin, vos mensonges recouvrent
une ineptie industrielle et un
saccage environnemental.
Voilà l'horizon détestable et
anachronique auquel l'écologie des
macronistes condamne les
prochaines générations.
Alors que les hypocrites célèbrent
la panthéonisation de Missak
Manouchian, des associations se
sont levées contre cette
destruction des biens communs.
Plusieurs milliers d'opposants
rassemblés dans une manifestation
organisée par les Soulèvements de
la Terre ont fait la démonstration
du côté où se trouvait le respect
de l'écologie de notre temps.
Fidèle à votre conception
autoritaire de notre démocratie,
votre régime sera-t-il un jour
capable de soulever un jour autre
chose que la matraque et le code
pénal?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Monsieur le
député, vous m'interrogez
finalement sur l'opportunité de
réaliser l'architecture magnifique
que sera le Lyon-Turin.
Mon opinion vous importe peu.
Mais vous pourriez peut-être
demander à monsieur Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui était ministre du
gouvernement de Lionel Jospin
lorsque ce gouvernement a souhaité
la construction de cet ouvrage.
Monsieur le député...
Je vous rappelle que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon a été ministre de Lionel
Jospin.
Ce n'est pas une insulte.
Monsieur Lionel Jospin est
quelqu'un de tout à fait
estimable.
Monsieur le député, j'ai envie de
vous demander si vous trouvez
normal que des parlementaires
manifestent lorsque le préfet
interdit une manifestation et que
la justice confirme cette
interdiction.
J'ai envie de vous demander si
votre groupe politique trouve
normal que nous puissions saisir
plus de 300 armes destinées à tuer
à la veille de cette
manifestation.
J'ai envie de vous demander si
vous pensez sérieusement que l'on
peut accepter que des personnes
radicalisées puissent participer à
des manifestations et que vous
puissiez ici soutenir qu'ils
étaient de gentilles personnes
simplement là pour protéger la
nature.
Vous êtes parfois un peu excessif,
monsieur le député.
Je vous cite: "La police est une
milice violente".
Autre citation: "La justice est
prostituée par le garde des
Sceaux".
Ce sont vos propos.
Vous avez parlé de "dictature
macroniste".
Monsieur le député, soutenez les
policiers et pas ceux qui les
agressent!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Bertrand Petit pour le
groupe socialiste.
- Bertrand Petit: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à la
Première ministre.
Dérembourser les médicaments,
c'est la dernière annonce de votre
gouvernement.
Dans le même temps, 8 millions de
Français subissent chaque jour les
difficultés dans l'accès aux
soins, en raison de la
désertification médicale.
Plus de médecin traitant, pas de
médecin près de chez soi, pas de
rendez-vous avant plusieurs mois.
Ils auraient le sentiment,
disiez-vous lors d'un déplacement,
que les services reculent.
Ce n'est pas un sentiment, madame
la Première ministre.
C'est la réalité.
Dans une démarche transpartisane,
un collègue a voulu flécher
l'installation des spécialistes et
des généralistes en fonction des
besoins de santé.
Ce serait la porte ouverte aux
déconventionnements, dites-vous.
Rien n'est prouvé.
Il faudrait insister, mais ça ne
suffit pas.
Que répondez-vous aux 74% de
Français favorables à
l'encadrement de l'installation
des médecins pour lutter contre
les déserts médicaux?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à François Braun,
ministre de la Santé et de la
Prévention.
- François Braun: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député Bertrand Petit,
vous me permettrez de ne pas
rejouer le match.
Il y a eu des débats extrêmement
nourris dans cette Assemblée.
Je remercie les groupes qui y ont
participé.
Ca a permis de faire des échanges
d'idées très constructifs.
Les déserts médicaux sont une
priorité forte.
Nous travaillons avec Agnès Firmin
Le Bodo pour améliorer la
situation de nos concitoyens.
Il y a trois grands axes de
travail.
Le premier, c'est augmenter le
nombre de professionnels de santé.
Nous avons pu faire sauter le
numerus clausus.
Nous avons aussi pu augmenter le
nombre d'étudiants infirmiers.
Nous voulons aussi favoriser
l'installation et le maintien des
médecins dans les territoires les
plus défavorisés.
Nous voulons améliorer les
conditions de travail des
professionnels.
Ils souhaitent avoir un exercice
pluriprofessionnel.
Nous déployons cela.
Nous voulons rapprocher les
étudiants de ces régions.
C'est l'enjeu de la quatrième
année d'études de médecine.
Il faut travailler avec l'ensemble
des professionnels de santé.
Nous le faisons par le partage et
le transfert de compétences.
Nous refondons complètement aussi
le métier d'infirmière pour qu'il
corresponde plus aux besoins
actuels.
Ce n'est pas de l'immobilisme.
Ce sont des solutions qui sont
éprouvées, qui fonctionnent, qui
permettent de faire venir des
professionnels dans les
territoires, contrairement à ce
que vous évoquez.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Une réponse,
monsieur Bertrand Petit?
- Bertrand Petit: Parmi vos
solutions, il y a aussi les
médicobus.
100 médicobus, c'est une rustine.
Les Français demandent des
médecins généralistes ancrés dans
les territoires.
Pas des médecins itinérants et
intermittents.
Les Français sont sûrement pas
tous égaux devant la santé, mais
ils doivent l'être dans l'accès
aux soins.
Agissez, s'il vous plaît.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Benjamin
Saint-Huile.
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Economie et des Finances.
C'est la fin du "quoi qu'il en
coûte".
Souvent, le ministre Le Maire l'a
scandé comme une perspective
immédiate.
Il faut désendetter la France,
selon lui.
Malgré un contexte d'inflation que
personne ne peut nier, vous avez
fait le choix d'annoncer la fin
des boucliers tarifaires pour le
gaz et pour l'électricité.
C'est la fin de la politique des
chèques.
Votre objectif est d'économiser 10
milliards d'euros.
C'est une petite somme, au regard
du déficit colossal qui est celui
de la France.
Vous aurez du mal à atteindre ces
objectifs.
Une fois encore, vous manquez de
méthode.
Vous n'avez pas su mettre autour
de la table l'ensemble des parties
prenantes qui fondent la dépense
publique et qui sont en mesure de
faire des propositions.
Vous y allez à l'aveugle et au
pif.
Vous essayez de trouver des pistes
d'économies.
Résultat des courses: vous
choisissez la santé en pointant du
doigt les médecins qui font des
arrêts de travail "de confort",
qui font en sorte de prescrire
"trop de médicaments".
Cela aura un impact sur nos
concitoyens qui paieront plus en
étant moins remboursés.
Vous passez sur le logement avec
la loi Pinel.
Pourtant, il s'agit des priorités
des Français au quotidien,
notamment autour du pouvoir
d'achat.
Vous refusez dans le même temps
par dogmatisme toute hypothèse de
recette nouvelle autour de la
taxation du grand capital ou du
grand patrimoine.
N'en avez-vous pas marre de faire
des cadeaux toujours aux mêmes et
de presser toujours ceux qui font
la France?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Gabriel Attal,
ministre délégué chargé des
Comptes publics.
- Gabriel Attal: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur le député
Saint-Huile, la plus grande
politique d'austérité pour la
France, ce serait de laisser filer
la dette comme le proposent
certains dans cet hémicycle.
Elle nous coûterait tellement cher
qu'il faudrait couper brutalement
dans la dépense publique.
Ce n'est pas ce que nous
souhaitons.
Il faut garder le contrôle de nos
finances publiques.
Nous avons établi un programme de
stabilité qui va nous permettre
effectivement de désendetter la
France en revenant sous les 3% de
déficit, progressivement, et en
commençant à rembourser notre
dette.
Nous avons une stratégie.
La première, c'est la croissance
et l'activité économique.
L'activité économique doit
continuer de se déployer dans
notre pays.
Ca peut passer par certaines
baisses de fiscalité.
On collecte plus d'impôts sur les
sociétés avec un taux à 25% qu'on
en collectait avec un taux à 33%.
Ca permet à l'activité économique
de se développer.
Il faut sortir des boucliers
tarifaires.
Le gaz, cette année, ensuite
l'électricité fin 2024.
Il faut dire la vérité aux
Français.
On ne peut pas garder ces
dispositifs généraux.
Les finances publiques ne nous le
permettent pas.
Ce serait des augmentations
d'impôts pour les Français, ce que
nous ne souhaitons pas.
Nous allons travailler dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent
avec le Parlement.
Nous avons engagé le dialogue avec
Bercy.
Nous allons reprendre ces
dialogues dans une version
augmentée et étendue avec François
Braun.
Nous allons échanger avec la
représentation nationale sur la
tenue de nos comptes publics.
J'espère que vous participerez à
ces travaux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Jean-Carles
Grelier.
- Jean-Carles Grelier: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Santé et de la Prévention.
Monsieur le ministre, c'est sur la
base d'un double constat que je
souhaite vous interpeller.
Le premier constat tient dans le
fait que l'on produise désormais
très peu de médicaments en France.
Depuis plusieurs années, des pans
entiers de l'industrie
pharmaceutique ont quitté notre
territoire pour se délocaliser
dans des pays à bas coût de
main-d'oeuvre et de production.
Il est probable que les
contraintes tarifaires et autres
clauses de sauvegarde n'aient pas
contribué à améliorer la
situation.
L'autre constat, c'est que de
nombreux médicaments sont
régulièrement en rupture
d'approvisionnement.
Cela laisse nombre de nos
compatriotes dans l'angoisse d'une
rupture de traitement.
Lors de son dernier déplacement en
Ardèche, le président de la
République a fait quelques
annonces fortes qui étaient
nécessaires, tant pour renouer des
relations de confiance avec
l'industrie du médicament que pour
les patients qui ont un grand
besoin d'être rassurés.
La production de 50 médicaments
jugés "critiques" va
progressivement revenir en France.
Il y a des stocks de 450
médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur qui vont être
scrutés et suivis de près par vos
services.
Qu'envisagez-vous pour redonner
envie aux industriels du
médicament de revenir investir en
France?
Comment seront mis en oeuvre les
engagements du dernier Conseil
stratégique des industries de
santé?
La loi de financement de la
Sécurité sociale pour 2024
marquera-t-elle une rupture avec
les précédentes en se traduisant
par une politique tarifaire moins
sévère et des clauses de
sauvegarde?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à François Braun.
- François Braun: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député, le problème de
pénurie de médicaments n'est pas
un problème que français.
C'est au minimum un problème
européen, voire au-delà.
C'est le sujet de la dernière
réunion des ministres de la Santé
à l'échelle européenne.
C'est un problème que nous devons
subir en France, mais aussi en
Europe, et notre objectif est de
retrouver notre souveraineté par
rapport à la production et à la
distribution de médicaments.
J'ai eu l'occasion d'annoncer la
semaine dernière une liste de 450
médicaments essentiels.
Ils sont définis par les sociétés
savantes médicales pour maintenir
le traitement de l'ensemble des
Français sur le territoire.
Parmi ces médicaments, il y en a
qui font partie de la liste dont
vous parliez, de médicaments
thérapeutiques majeurs.
D'autres n'en font pas partie,
mais vont intégrer ce principe de
médicaments essentiels.
L'enjeu est de contrôler
l'ensemble de la production de ces
médicaments, depuis l'usine
jusqu'à la boîte, dans la
pharmacie.
On a pu voir l'hiver dernier les
incohérences entre ce que disaient
les industriels et ce que les
pharmaciens remontaient comme
difficultés.
Le président de la République a
annoncé une relocalisation.
Les choses seront précisées
prochainement.
L'enjeu est double: rendre
accessibles les médicaments en
rupture les plus innovants pour
les Français.
La Première ministre a lancé des
discussions.
Nous attendons des conclusions qui
permettront de définir les grands
axes à venir.
Notre préoccupation, c'est
d'assurer les médicaments les plus
innovants pour tous les Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Aymeric Caron.
- Aymeric Caron: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la Première ministre,
mercredi dernier, au large de la
Grèce, la mer a avalé les vies de
plusieurs centaines d'hommes, de
femmes et d'enfants.
Des exilés qui tentaient de vivre
mieux ailleurs.
Il s'agit de l'un des naufrages
les plus meurtriers jamais vu en
Méditerranée.
On estime qu'il y a environ 600
morts, parmi lesquels une centaine
d'enfants noyés avec leur mère
dans la cale de leur bateau
cercueil.
En leur mémoire, je propose,
mesdames et messieurs les
ministres et chers collègues, que
nous observions une minute de
silence.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Mais oui,
mais...
Je trouve effectivement que cette
idée est formidable, mais la
conférence des présidents est là
pour ça, pour que nous puissions
décider collectivement des moments
dans lesquels nous honorons les
personnes disparues.
On ne fait pas de minute de
silence de cette façon-là, vous
devriez le savoir.
C'est désolant, car ce sont des
moments qui doivent nous unir et
pas nous désunir.
Des pratiques telles que celle-là
nous déshonorent.
J'en suis navrée.
Brouhaha
...
Monsieur Caron, vous poursuivez
votre question?
- Aymeric Caron: Merci.
Je ne vois pas pourquoi
l'improvisation de ce moment
empêchait l'union.
Ce silence en guise d'hommage ne
doit pas nous en faire oublier un
autre, à savoir le silence gêné et
coupable qui accompagne, depuis
une semaine, ce drame.
Nous laissons mourir des êtres
humains parce qu'ils nous gênent!
Parce que leur origine, leur
couleur de peau ou leur religion
ne nous conviennent pas.
Nous les enterrons en mer.
Près de 27.000 personnes sont
mortes en Méditerranée depuis 10
ans.
L'Europe et la France ne font
rien, ou presque.
Ma question est la suivante, que
mettez-vous en oeuvre pour éviter
que de telles tragédies ne se
reproduisent?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Chrysoula
Zacharopoulou.
- Chrysoula Zacharopoulou: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Monsieur le député, ce naufrage
survenu le 14 juin est avant tout
un drame effroyable.
Je souhaite d'abord redire la
profonde tristesse de la France et
renouveler nos condoléances aux
familles des victimes.
Je veux aussi rappeler l'entière
mobilisation de la France avec
l'ensemble de ses partenaires
européens pour faire en sorte que
ce type de tragédie ne se
reproduise pas.
Je salue à ce titre l'accord
trouvé le 8 juin par les ministres
européens de l'Intérieur.
Il faut apporter une réponse
européenne efficace aux demandes
d'asile.
Il faut mettre en oeuvre
concrètement la solidarité entre
les Etats-membres.
Ce drame rappelle aussi
l'importance de la coopération
avec les pays tiers en matière de
sauvetage en mer et de lutte
contre les réseaux des passeurs.
Les travaux sont en cours au
niveau européen, et en particulier
avec la Tunisie.
Notre objectif est de renforcer
les capacités des Etats d'origine
et de transit.
Nous voulons mieux lutter contre
ceux qui exploitent la détresse
des migrants et mieux lutter
contre les causes profondes de
leur exil.
C'est ainsi que nous éviterons de
nouvelles tragédies.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Emilie Bonnivard.
- Emilie Bonnivard: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à la
Première ministre.
Samedi, en Maurienne, des
individus violents sont venus
caillasser les forces de l'ordre,
vandaliser un garage, paralyser
toute la circulation ferroviaire
et routière en Savoie, effrayer
les habitants du secteur au nom de
l'écologie.
Tout cela, avec le soutien de
députés insoumis et écolo venus
faire leur buzz sur le dos des
Savoyards, aux côtés des casseurs.
C'est une honte.
J'ai été choquée, comme des
millions de nos compatriotes.
Je veux dire toute notre
reconnaissance aux forces de
l'ordre, gendarmes, douaniers,
pompiers, soignants engagés en
Maurienne qui ont permis d'éviter
le pire.
Face à la désinformation, il faut
rappeler que le Lyon-Turin est la
seule infrastructure permettant un
fret massif et d'améliorer la
qualité de l'air et de la vie dans
nos vallées, sans sacrifier le
transport de voyageurs, ni les
habitants vivant aux abords de la
ligne historique en toute
sécurité.
Les Suisses ont réalisé la même
infrastructure nord-sud.
Ils ont toujours de l'eau, chers
collègues.
Ils n'ont pas vidé les Alpes.
Demandez à monsieur Mélenchon d'y
faire un tour.
Nous, c'est seulement 8%, avec
l'Italie par le rail.
Nous subissons la congestion du
trafic en Maurienne, en
Haute-Savoie et dans les
Alpes-Maritimes.
Qui va payer les dégradations
locales de ce garage, les
Soulèvements de la Terre?
Les groupes LFI et écologistes?
Pouvez-vous réaffirmer la volonté
du gouvernement de faire du
Lyon-Turin une priorité?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Bérangère
Couillard, secrétaire d'Etat à
l'Ecologie.
- Bérangère Couillard: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Madame la députée Bonnivard, vous
nous interrogez sur le projet LGV
Lyon-Turin.
Je tiens à remercier les forces de
l'ordre mobilisées ce week-end en
Maurienne pour empêcher ces
débordements insupportables.
12 gendarmes ont été blessés.
C'est inacceptable.
L'opposition à un projet
d'infrastructure ne justifie pas
le recours à la violence.
Le projet est ambitieux.
Les travaux sont engagés et font
l'objet d'un accord international
entre la France et l'Italie.
Il est soutenu sans ambiguïté par
le gouvernement.
Le projet Lyon-Turin est
nécessaire et très attendu des
deux côtés des Alpes.
Près d'un million de poids lourds
pourront être basculés sur le
rail.
C'est une nécessité écologique.
Nous sommes le seul pays à ne pas
voir ce type de tunnel dans notre
infrastructure.
C'est important de le rappeler.
Il comprend aussi la partie nord
du contournement ferroviaire de
l'agglomération lyonnaise, qu'il
est important de soulager.
Je vous sais aussi très soucieuse
sur le financement du projet.
C'est un total de 10 milliards
d'euros dont nous parlons, dont 6
milliards qui restent à financer
en prenant en compte la
participation attendue de l'Union
Européenne sur ce sujet.
Le ministre des Transports Clément
Beaune a été très clair.
L'Etat est prêt à prendre la
moitié, soit 3 milliards d'euros.
C'est un engagement majeur.
Nous attendons aussi des
collectivités locales qu'elles
puissent abonder pour arriver au
montant global.
Il faut réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre qui sont
insupportables sur le territoire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Béatrice Bellamy.
- Béatrice Bellamy: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à
Jean-Christophe Combe, ministre
des Personnes handicapées.
Monsieur le ministre, je souhaite
vous alerter sur la situation
inquiétante des structures
d'accueil des personnes âgées,
médicalisées ou non, du secteur
public ou associatif.
Nos EHPAD, nos résidences
autonomie sont en danger.
Le 13 décembre dernier, j'ai
exprimé ce que de nombreux élus et
gestionnaires des EHPAD
ressentaient, une inquiétude quant
à l'avenir de leurs structures.
Les finances sont très
inquiétantes et les trésoreries au
plus bas.
Dans ma circonscription, plusieurs
maires ont fait manger des
résidents dans leur chambre pour
optimiser les temps de travail.
Certaines structures menacent de
fermer pour les trois mois d'été.
Pourront-elles rouvrir?
D'autres mobilisent des lignes de
trésorerie qui auront leurs
limites.
Dans mon département, le taux de
chômage est au plus bas.
5%, je m'en réjouis.
La conséquence du manque de bras
devient difficile à juguler.
Face à ces difficultés, les
leviers financiers et RH
mobilisables sont souvent des
voeux pieux.
Les ARS locales sont démunies.
La réponse ne peut venir que de
l'Etat et elle est urgente.
J'ai bien conscience qu'aucune
mesure ne pourra solutionner les
difficultés de recrutement en
quelques semaines.
Aussi, monsieur le ministre,
pouvez-vous nous indiquer quelles
sont les nouvelles mesures
envisagées pour mieux accompagner
nos structures?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Jean-Christophe
Combe.
- Jean-Christophe Combe: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Madame la députée Bellamy, je vous
remercie pour votre question et
permettez-moi de commencer ma
réponse en félicitant et en
remerciant l'ensemble des
personnels qui sont aujourd'hui
engagés dans nos établissements
pour protéger et accompagner nos
aînés.
Ils le font à la force de leur
engagement dans des conditions qui
sont souvent particulièrement
difficiles.
Je suis à leur côté, en
particulier en ce moment pour
préparer cette période estivale
qui sera à n'en pas douter
difficile.
J'espère qu'ils pourront traverser
ces mois extrêmement tendus.
Je veux vous dire aussi que le
Conseil national de la refondation
dédié au bien-vieillir a présenté
ses conclusions.
La situation financière que vous
décrivez, nous la connaissons.
J'ai mobilisé les ARS aux côtés
des départements pour suivre la
situation de chaque établissement.
Nous ne laisserons aucun
établissement sur le bord du
chemin.
On a triplé les crédits non
reconductibles cet été.
Les réponses structurelles
viendront dans la feuille de route
dédiée au bien-vieillir.
Nous allons renforcer
l'attractivité de ces métiers.
On apportera des réponses
structurelles quant au modèle
économique de ces structures, que
ce soit les résidences autonomie
ou les EHPAD.
La mission conduite en ce moment
permettra d'apporter des réponses
structurelles.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Jorys Bovet.
- Jorys Bovet: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Economie et des Finances.
Monsieur le ministre, nous sommes
le 20 juin.
Depuis 10 jours, un tiers des
Français n'ont plus que 100 euros
maximum de reste à vivre sur leur
compte en banque.
100 euros pour manger, faire le
plein, aller travailler,
entretenir son véhicule.
100 euros pour toutes ces dépenses
si essentielles.
3 Français sur 5 ont réduit leurs
dépenses alimentaires, faute de
moyens.
1 Français sur 2 saute des repas.
40% repoussent des soins.
Ce sera sans doute aggravé suite
aux dernières annonces.
La liste de l'inacceptable est
longue.
Vous minimisez pourtant la
détresse dans laquelle se trouvent
tous ces Français.
Ne pas pouvoir payer ses factures,
se retrouver à découvert, c'est
une charge mentale énorme pour
ceux qui vivent ces situations.
Les troubles psychologiques vont
de pair avec les difficultés
financières.
Vous allez me répondre que vous
entendez les inquiétudes.
Les Français ne sont pas dupes de
votre enfumage.
Trois quarts d'entre eux jugent
que vous ne faites pas assez pour
lutter contre l'inflation.
Les Français attendent que vous
écoutiez les représentants que
nous sommes.
Depuis un an dans cet hémicycle,
les députés du RN réclament ces
mesures fortes pour le pouvoir
d'achat des Français.
Baissez la TVA sur l'énergie,
supprimez-la sur 100 produits de
première nécessité.
La moitié des Français n'auront
pas le plaisir des vacances.
Quand allez-vous décider de
prendre les mesures efficaces pour
permettre aux concitoyens de
sortir la tête de l'eau?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivia Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Depuis un an, c'est la même
chanson.
La seule différence, c'est que
nous agissons.
Vous n'avez rien voté.
Quand on parle d'enfumage, il faut
être précis.
Vous n'avez rien voté depuis un an
pour soulager le pouvoir d'achat
des Français.
Rien!
Ni le bouclier tarifaire, ni
l'aide exceptionnelle de rentrée,
ni la revalorisation des bourses,
ni la revalorisation des APL, ni
l'indemnité de carburant.
Vous n'avez rien voté.
Je pourrais vous rappeler que nous
avons mis 46 milliards d'euros sur
le bouclier tarifaire pour
soulager la douloureuse de nos
compatriotes.
Je pourrais vous rappeler que nous
avons mis en place un trimestre
anti-inflation qui démontre que
les prix baissent.
Je pourrais vous rappeler que nous
avons sollicité les industriels
pour qu'en ce moment même, les
prix soient en train de baisser.
Vous, le RN, vous, en un an, une
seule proposition pour soulager le
pouvoir d'achat.
Une proposition qui coûterait 10
milliards d'euros aux
contribuables.
Une proposition qui ne fournirait
aucun effet aux consommateurs.
Quand on parle d'enfumage, vous
savez de quoi vous parlez.
Rendez-vous la semaine prochaine.
Une énième question sur la TVA,
c'est toujours la même chanson.
En attendant, nous agissons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Une réponse,
monsieur Bovet?
- Jorys Bovet: Vous dites que nous
n'avons pas de solutions?
Là, nous vous en avons proposé
deux.
Vous avez déjà essayé de survivre
avec le SMIC?
Vous peut-être pas, mais moi, oui.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Chantal Jourdan.
- Chantal Jourdan: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Selon les associations, 47.000
personnes en situation de handicap
en France sont sans solution
d'accueil, dont 8000 enfants qui
sont privés de leur droit à
l'éducation.
Suite à une réclamation des
associations, avec le concours de
la Commission nationale des droits
de l'homme et du Défenseur des
droits, la France s'est vue
notifier ses manquements en
matière d'accompagnement, de
services de soutien, d'accès au
logement et de santé.
Ce sont les droits des personnes
en situation de handicap et de
leurs familles qui sont bafoués.
Le président de la République a
fait des annonces lors de la
Conférence nationale du handicap.
Il a présenté des mesures qui
constituent une juste continuation
des efforts à conduire.
Néanmoins, les associations
dénoncent un manque de
transparence qui voile une réelle
ambition de société inclusive.
Cette ambition aurait nécessité
d'en clarifier les contours et un
plan pluriannuel.
Nous devons venir à l'aide des
enfants en situation de handicap.
Une articulation est nécessaire
entre les structures
médico-sociales et le monde du
travail.
Il faut également une vraie
reconnaissance de la fonction
d'accompagnant.
Il est urgent de se pencher sur le
besoin imminent des enfants qui
sont aujourd'hui mal scolarisés.
Je pense aux ULIS.
Je demande quels sont les mesures
efficientes qui vont être mises en
place sur le sujet.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Geneviève Darrieussecq.
- Geneviève Darrieussecq: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Madame la députée, je vous
remercie de votre question qui
permet de mettre le focus sur un
sujet qui nous tient à coeur.
"L'inclusion" est un mot que je
n'aime pas beaucoup parce qu'il
est toujours à sens unique.
La philosophie de l'inclusion,
c'est aussi que notre société
devienne inclusive, que nous
luttions contre les stéréotypes et
que notre société connaisse mieux
le handicap, afin d'accepter et de
comprendre quels sont les sujets
et quels sont les besoins des
personnes en situation de
handicap.
Lors de la Conférence nationale du
handicap, le président de la
République a lancé des mesures
fortes, notamment dans
l'accessibilité, qui est en retard
dans notre pays à tous les
niveaux.
Il y a eu des propositions de
création d'accompagnement auprès
des publics qui en ont besoin.
2 milliards d'euros seront mis sur
la table.
Nous allons les décliner en
étalement pluriannuel, afin de
donner de la visibilité à ces
solutions.
Nous allons travailler avec les
présidents de conseils
départementaux afin que la
structuration de l'offre pour les
personnes en situation de handicap
soit adaptée aux besoins des
territoires.
Je voulais dire aussi que nous
avons un manque.
Nous manquons de données
consolidées à l'échelle de tous
les territoires.
J'ai lancé un grand appel à tous
les acteurs du secteur, afin
d'avoir ces données nationales et
départementales qui nous aideront
à construire des solutions.
J'étais à l'ONU la semaine
dernière.
J'ai parlé des droits, j'ai parlé
de l'effectivité des droits.
Nous sommes tout à fait en phase
avec ces objectifs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Patricia Lemoine du
groupe Renaissance.
- Patricia Lemoine: Ma question
s'adresse à madame Dominique
Faure, ministre déléguée chargée
des Collectivités territoriales et
de la ruralité.
Dans un 21e siècle qui a eu
tendance à favoriser l'urbain,
nombre de nos ruralités luttent
pour éviter leur déclin.
Elles luttent pour accueillir un
médecin, pour maintenir une école,
pour créer une ligne de bus.
Les ruralités sont au coeur des
préoccupations du gouvernement
depuis 2017.
Les services publics, le
numérique, la mobilité, la santé,
le logement, c'est autant de
sujets pour lesquels des solutions
concrètes ont été déployées, à
travers notamment l'agenda rural
ou encore l'ANCT, ou le plan
France très haut débit.
Cette année marque un nouveau
tournant dans cette ambition avec
l'annonce du plan France
Ruralités.
Il est prévu plusieurs mesures
visant à répondre aux
problématiques les plus tenaces, à
travers notamment le déploiement
de bus médicaux et la
pérennisation du fonds pour les
commerces ruraux.
Je pense également au fonds pour
les mobilités du dernier
kilomètre.
Les habitants des territoires
ruraux seront particulièrement
attentifs au déploiement de ces
dispositifs, notamment sur notre
capacité à attirer des médecins
volontaires pour les bus médicaux.
Pouvez-vous nous expliquer comment
vont se décliner ces mesures?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Dominique Faure.
- Dominique Faure: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée, je veux saluer
le travail qui a été réalisé par
Jacqueline Gourault sur l'agenda
rural.
C'est plusieurs milliards qui ont
été investis ces dernières années.
Cet agenda rural poursuit son
développement et continue à
délivrer un certain nombre de
services.
Nous avons la nécessité de le
prolonger et de l'amplifier.
Cet agenda met les femmes et les
hommes de nos ruralités au coeur
de nos politiques publiques.
Vous avez cité les bus médicaux,
qui vont permettre à des
généralistes et des spécialistes
médicaux d'aller au contact des
habitants de nos ruralités.
Comment?
Il faudra se rapprocher des
préfets.
Il y aura des chefs d'ingénierie
qui seront aux côtés des préfets
pour cela.
Ces bus médicaux seront déployés à
compter de 2024.
Nous avons besoin de vrais lieux
de lien social.
Aujourd'hui, nous investissons
dans les commerces de proximité.
36 millions d'euros ont été mis
sur la table pour nos ruralités,
sur les trois années qui viennent.
Sur la mobilité, c'est pas moins
de 30 millions.
Notamment sur la mobilité du
dernier kilomètre: faire en sorte
que l'on puisse se rendre à la
gare ou au dernier arrêt de bus.
Les préfets vont travailler avec
leurs interlocuteurs dans les
ruralités.
C'est là que nous avons besoin de
cette ingénierie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, madame la ministre.
La parole est à monsieur Damien
Maudet pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Damien Maudet: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de la Santé.
Mais tout d'abord, j'ai une pensée
pour les soignants des hôpitaux en
grève aujourd'hui.
Voici ce qu'ils nous disent:
"Quand un patient arrive, j'en
fais quoi?
Je lui donne sa chance?
Il faut que je fasse des choix."
Ces mots, ces alertes, n'importe
quel député les entendra s'il se
rend dans un hôpital près de chez
lui.
L'hôpital public est en voie
d'effondrement.
Monsieur le ministre, tout est en
train d'empirer.
Un infirmier sur trois souhaite
démissionner avant la fin de
l'année.
Les pires records sont battus.
Pourtant, dans une interview
récente, vous avez dit aborder les
choses avec sérénité.
Cet hiver, les médecins ont dû
intuber des enfants dans les
couloirs, faute de place.
Et vous, vous êtes serein?
Des patients attendent des heures
sur des brancards, certains
meurent sur les brancards.
Ca a été le cas à Rouen.
Et vous, vous êtes serein?
La vérité, c'est de nous dire
combien de décès il vous faudra
avant de vous faire réagir.
Vous êtes serein parce que vous
continuez à annoncer des économies
parce que vous ne manquerez jamais
de lit.
L'élite du pays ne manquera jamais
de médecins pour se faire soigner.
Vous êtes en train de créer un
système de santé à deux vitesses.
Nous avions le meilleur système de
santé du monde, rendez-le-nous!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur François Braun,
ministre de la Santé.
- François Braun: Monsieur le
député, heureusement que nous
n'avons pas attendu votre alerte
pour nous occuper de l'hôpital
public et des soignants.
Vous revenez sans cesse sur les
crises que nous avons eues cet
hiver, sur des enfants entre la
vie et la mort dans les couloirs
de l'hôpital.
Ce n'était pas le cas, je vous
rassure.
Je vais vous parler de l'hôpital
public, monsieur le député.
Je le connais un peu, quand même.
L'hôpital public, c'est aussi ce
monsieur de 65 ans qui fait une
paralysie, soudainement.
Sa femme appelle le SAMU et les
urgences.
Il est conduit à l'hôpital.
Il passe une I.R.M.
Il a fait un AVC.
Cela débouchera sur une
intervention qui permettra de le
sauver.
L'hôpital, ce n'est pas que des
situations catastrophiques.
Je rends hommage à ces soignants
qui sont là tous les jours et
toutes les nuits pour aider les
patients.
La majorité travaille pour
l'hôpital public.
Elle investit dans l'hôpital
public.
Mon objectif principal, c'est
d'améliorer leur qualité de vie au
travail, de diminuer toutes les
contraintes administratives, de
faciliter le travail des services,
de sortir de la tarification à
l'activité.
Cela peut vous paraître technique,
mais c'est comme cela que nous
sortirons des difficultés à
l'hôpital.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
député?
- Damien Maudet: Je n'ai pas le
sentiment d'avoir eu réellement
une réponse.
Vous nous dites que l'hôpital
soigne, c'est sa fonction.
L'hôpital est à l'agonie.
Où est l'ancien syndicaliste que
vous étiez?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Matthieu Marchio pour
le Rassemblement National.
- Matthieu Marchio: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre délégué aux
Transports.
En annonçant la liquidation de
fret SNCF, vous avez obéi aux
injonctions de la Commission
européenne qui dénonçait les aides
financières à cette entreprise.
Une fois encore, l'idéologie
ultralibérale de Bruxelles va
casser une entreprise publique.
L'ouverture à la concurrence du
fret n'a pas eu l'impact attendu.
Dans la gare de ma
circonscription, 500 emplois ont
été supprimés en 15 ans.
Quel résultat catastrophique, dans
un territoire qui n'avait pas
besoin de cela!
Songez à l'absurdité d'un système
où, au nom des règles européennes,
la SNCF a été découpée en
plusieurs filiales.
Le serpent se mord la queue.
Et cela, avec l'argent des
Français.
Malgré vos belles promesses
appelant à la relance du fret, ce
sont les élus européens
macronistes qui ont détruit le
fret ferroviaire et ont laissé des
salariés sur le carreau.
De nombreuses voies sont fermées
et deviennent impraticables par
manque d'entretien.
Au niveau national, au nom de tous
ces ouvriers, de tous ces agents
de fret, je vous demande quand
vous allez oeuvrer pour que les
Etats-membres de l'Union
Européenne retrouvent leur
souveraineté en termes de
transport.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Bérangère Couillard,
ministre chargée de l'Ecologie.
- Bérangère Couillard: Monsieur le
député, le fret ferroviaire, en
particulier public, reste un
secteur stratégique auquel la
majorité et le gouvernement sont
extrêmement attachés.
En janvier 2023, la Commission
européenne a ouvert une procédure
formelle sur les conditions de
financement du fret à la SNCF.
Nous travaillons sur le sujet,
dans un esprit de responsabilité
et loin de tout esprit de
démagogie facile.
Plutôt que de prendre le risque de
voir disparaître le fret
ferroviaire français dans les mois
qui viennent, nous assumons de
travailler en lien avec la
Commission sur la mise en place
d'une discontinuité raisonnable.
Je ne vous laisserai pas dire que
nous cédons aux diktats de
Bruxelles.
Nous avons marqué des lignes
rouges.
Pas de licenciement, pas de
privatisation, pas de reports sur
la route.
Pour garantir la continuité de
l'exploitation, l'Etat va lancer
prochainement un appel à
manifestation d'intérêt pour
identifier un repreneur.
Le fret ferroviaire continuera de
rouler, quelle que soit la
nouvelle étiquette de l'opérateur.
Tout cela se fait dans le contexte
d'une accélération de dans les
infrastructures dédiées aux fret
-- au fret ferroviaire.
C'est plus de 4 milliards d'euros
d'investissement d'ici 2032.
Les aides à l'exploitation
accordées pendant le plan de
relance seront augmentées d'ici la
fin 2024, à 200 millions d'euros
et elles seront également
prolongées jusqu'en 2030.
Vous le voyez, le gouvernement est
totalement mobilisé.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
député?
- Matthieu Marchio: Derrière ce
bla-bla technocratique, c'est 20%
de l'activité qui risque d'être
touchée.
500 emplois risquent d'être
supprimés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Nicolas Turquois pour
le groupe démocrate.
- Nicolas Turquois: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
du Travail.
Le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites, le COR, a transmis les
éléments de son rapport annuel
cette semaine.
La presse s'en fait l'écho.
Ce nouveau rapport questionne.
Il y a quelques mois, le COR
évoquait "d'éventuels déficits de
notre régime de retraite de
l'ordre de l'épaisseur du trait".
Les résultats du rapport ne
validaient pas "le bien-fondé des
discours qui valident une dépense
non-contrôlée des dépenses de
retraite".
Les conclusions qui paraissent à
présent font le constat inverse.
Si le rapport était positif
concernant la réforme sur les plus
petites pensions, il y a sinon un
renversement d'analyse quasiment
complet.
Le Commissariat au plan avait
pointé des déficits structurels de
l'ordre de 30 milliards d'euros.
Mais les oppositions avaient
préféré relayer les doutes émis
par le COR, alimentant ainsi la
contestation sociale.
Nous avons besoin d'analyses
responsables et objectives.
Manifestement, cela n'a pas été le
cas.
Il convient d'en tirer des
enseignements.
Au groupe démocrate, nous
souhaiterions que les partenaires
sociaux soient davantage associés
au pilotage du régime des
retraites, cela a déjà fait ses
preuves.
Nous pensons qu'une réflexion doit
être menée sur le fonctionnement
ou le dysfonctionnement du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites.
Nous aimerions connaître votre
position sur ce sujet, monsieur le
ministre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci, monsieur
le député.
Vous m'interrogez sur le rapport
que le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites aura à examiner demain.
Comme vous l'avez dit, les
documents publiés sont une sorte
de pré-rapport.
Je comprends vos interrogations.
Il y a quelques mois, le même
Conseil d'orientation des
retraites expliquait qu'il n'y
avait pas le feu au lac, et
aujourd'hui, il annonce des
déficits d'un montant assez
conséquent.
Il évoque le chiffre de 8
milliards d'euros.
Il y a 5 ans, en 2017, nous avions
vécu le même phénomène, avec des
prédictions complètement
différentes à 6 mois d'intervalle.
Nous pouvons tirer des
enseignements de ce rapport, pour
ce que nous en connaissons.
Si nous n'avions pas fait cette
réforme, le déficit serait encore
bien plus supérieur que ce qui est
annoncé par le COR.
Ceux qui nous annonçaient il y a
quelques semaines qu'il n'y avait
pas d'urgence à faire la réforme,
ils nous annoncent aujourd'hui un
déficit important à hauteur de 30
milliards d'euros.
Cela confirme le courage de tous
les députés et de tous les
sénateurs qui ont soutenu cette
démarche et cette réforme.
Le deuxième enseignement, c'est
que cette réforme produit ses
premiers effets.
Dans ce rapport, nous voyons que
la réforme va permettre de
garantir le système par
répartition.
Mais cela montre aussi que la
réforme permet de mieux traiter et
de mieux accompagner celles et
ceux qui ont des carrières longues
et des carrières hachées.
Cela va aider les salariés les
plus modestes à avoir une retraite
plus importante.
La génération 84, grâce à ce
rapport, aura une retraite 10%
supérieure à ce qu'elle aurait été
avant la réforme.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Nathalie Bassire.
- Nathalie Bassire: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre délégué au
Logement.
La crise du logement touche
l'Hexagone, mais encore plus les
outre-mer.
Une crise grave se profile à La
Réunion.
La fin du dispositif Pinel en 2024
et son non-remplacement, cela va
avoir un effet multiplié à La
Réunion.
Nous avons une population qui tend
vers 1 million d'ici 10 à 15 ans.
Il faut aller au-delà de la simple
rénovation de l'espace locatif.
La crise sanitaire a entraîné
l'arrêt des chantiers.
La crise internationale et ses
conséquences, l'explosion du coût
des matériaux de construction,
cela a mis les entreprises du
bâtiment à genoux.
Il y a également une raréfaction
de l'offre de logements.
En cause, la spéculation
immobilière et l'augmentation des
prix de loyer, résultant de la
présence en augmentation des
non-réunionnais.
De nombreuses difficultés pour
s'installer seul ou en couple sont
rencontrées par les jeunes
Réunionnais.
Cela génère des tensions.
On pourrait débattre des effets
pervers de certains dispositifs
outre-mer.
Mais aujourd'hui, retirer la
dernière incitation fiscale à
l'investissement locatif dans le
neuf, cela équivaut à sacrifier
des professionnels de la
construction et de l'immobilier.
Monsieur le ministre, je vous le
demande solennellement, quelles
sont les mesures spécifiques qui
vont être prises par le
gouvernement pour éviter une grave
crise du logement dans les
territoires d'outre-mer?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Klein.
- Olivier Klein: Madame la
députée, votre question me donne
l'occasion de rappeler les
annonces fortes faites par la
Première ministre lors de son
déplacement à La Réunion.
Le passage d'une aide de 30 à 50%
sur la réhabilitation.
Nous avons également étendu la
totalité du crédit d'impôt au
logement social, ce qui était une
demande de l'ensemble des
territoires d'outre-mer.
Les primes de rénovation ont
également été l'objet d'une
extension.
En outre-mer, comme sur l'ensemble
du territoire hexagonal, nous
avons à privilégier la
réhabilitation du logement qui est
déjà là.
Ensuite, vous avez raison, il faut
accompagner le développement du
logement en outre-mer et sur le
territoire hexagonal.
Nous avons fait le choix de
supprimer une niche fiscale qui a
montré son efficacité, mais qui a
aussi créé des logements de
précarité.
Aujourd'hui, nous faisons le choix
de l'investissement locatif avec
des entreprises qui vont mieux
gérer ces logements.
Nous allons faire cela, y compris
dans nos territoires d'outre-mer.
Ensuite, nous continuerons à
développer le logement en
outre-mer avec les partenaires
locaux dans le cadre du pacte de
confiance que nous allons bientôt
signer.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Paul Midy pour le
groupe Renaissance.
- Paul Midy: Ma question s'adresse
au ministre délégué chargé de la
Transition numérique et des
Télécommunications.
Le salon VivaTech a eu lieu la
semaine dernière.
C'est le plus grand salon d'Europe
dédié aux start-ups.
Nos start-ups représentent
maintenant une part importante de
notre économie.
1,5 million d'emplois et surtout
un tiers de nos capacités à
atteindre le plein emploi dans nos
prochaines années.
A l'occasion de ce salon, le
président de la République a fait
plusieurs annonces importantes.
Il a annoncé des investissements
massifs pour doubler le nombre de
formations dans l'intelligence
artificielle et renforcer nos
capacités de calcul.
Sur le plan du financement, alors
que les levées de fonds ont
ralenti depuis plusieurs mois, le
président a annoncé la
mobilisation de 7 milliards
d'euros auprès des assureurs.
Pour aider nos plus jeunes
start-ups, le président a
également annoncé reprendre la
principale mesure du rapport que
je vous ai remis la semaine
dernière.
Il s'agit d'un dispositif à
destination des jeunes entreprises
pour soutenir les jeunes
entreprises innovantes, notamment
à lever des fonds et à gérer leur
trésorerie.
C'est 1,5 milliard d'euros par an
de fonds supplémentaires.
Le président a également annoncé
un programme d'accompagnement pour
nos meilleures start-ups
industrielles.
Enfin, vous avez annoncé un plan
ambitieux et concret pour
renforcer la commande publique et
privée à destination de nos
start-ups.
Aussi, monsieur le ministre,
pouvez-vous nous préciser
l'horizon de mise en oeuvre de ces
annonces très attendues?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Jean-Noël Barrot.
- Jean-Noël Barrot: Monsieur le
député, vous l'avez dit, la
septième édition du salon VivaTech
a été un très grand succès.
Je remercie toutes celles et ceux
qui ont participé à son
organisation.
Ce succès nous rappelle que,
depuis la première édition, il y a
huit ans, la France a renoué avec
sa nature profonde de grande
nation d'innovation et
d'entreprenariat.
Des dizaines de milliers
d'entreprises innovantes ont été
créées dans tous les territoires
de métropole et d'outre-mer.
A l'occasion de ce salon, la
Première ministre a annoncé neuf
nouveaux programmes de formation
et elle a lancé un programme qui
va permettre dès la rentrée
d'accompagner 10.000 jeunes filles
vers les métiers du numérique.
A cette occasion, le président de
la République a fait des annonces
majeures dont nous allons veiller
à la mise en oeuvre dans les
prochains mois.
Il y aura notamment des annonces
majeures sur l'intelligence
artificielle et le métavers, que
la France doit maîtriser coûte que
coûte.
Nous voulons permettre aux
entreprises innovantes dans notre
pays de bénéficier de
financements, d'accompagnement et
de clients.
Plusieurs initiatives seront mises
en oeuvre, y compris avec la
Fédération des assureurs.
Ces engagements seront concrétisés
dès la semaine prochaine.
125 entreprises seront
accompagnées par la recherche
publique.
Une autre initiative va rassembler
une cinquantaine d'acteurs
institutionnels qui s'engagent
pour faire doubler le recours aux
solutions des start-ups d'ici
2027.
Vous l'aurez compris, le
gouvernement agira résolument pour
faire en sorte que le gouvernement
investisse dans ces technologies
d'avenir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Catherine Couturier.
- Catherine Couturier: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Olivier Véran, porte-parole du
gouvernement.
Dans un entretien au Figaro,
Richard Ferrand a déclaré
regretter tout ce qui bride la
libre expression de la
souveraineté populaire.
Quelle surprise!
La macronie aurait-elle finalement
consenti à défendre la démocratie?
Non, monsieur Ferrand, petit
serviteur du monarque, souhaite
qu'Emmanuel Macron puisse briguer
un troisième mandat présidentiel.
Le valet du roi n'a pas digéré sa
défaite.
Il défend la voix de son maître
pour mériter le prochain poste de
Premier ministre.
Si certains en doutaient encore,
la preuve est là.
Notre démocratie et les valeurs de
la République sont bafouées.
Notre régime s'enfonce dans sa
dérive autoritaire.
Je rappelle quand même que les
deux derniers présidents à avoir
changé leur Constitution pour être
réélus sont Xi Jinping et Vladimir
Poutine, dirigeants autoritaires
tenant leur pays d'une main de
fer.
Votre gouvernement a accumulé
toutes les dérives.
Utilisation du 49.3 par 11 fois en
moins d'un an, utilisation de la
police pour réprimer les
manifestations, etc.
La vision de la politique en
macronie, c'est celle d'une élite
déconnectée qui cumule les
indemnités de mandat.
Votre vision du monde en fichier
Excel vous aura poussés à faire
une réforme des retraites dont
plus de 70% de la population ne
veut pas.
Monsieur le porte-parole du
gouvernement, si vous souhaitez
réellement la libre expression de
la souveraineté populaire,
êtes-vous prêt à remettre en place
le RIC, la reconnaissance du vote
blanc et la VIe République?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivier Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la députée, j'ai entendu...
Je n'ai pas tout compris au début
de la question.
Il y avait des applaudissements.
J'imagine que vous vouliez parler
du président Mélenchon, en
entendant parler de "dérive
autoritaire" et "voix de son
maître".
Vous parliez de Richard Ferrand?
Vous m'interpellez sur les propos
de Richard Ferrand, dont l'absence
ici semble vous être la plus
cruelle des présences.
J'imagine que son interview a été
très lue.
De toutes les interprétations,
celle que j'ai tendance à
privilégier, c'est celle de son
auteur, Richard Ferrand lui-même.
J'ajoute que chacun est libre de
répondre aux questions de la
presse.
Je crois qu'en politique, il n'est
pas interdit d'être sincère.
Aux polémiques et caricatures,
nous préférons l'action et la
raison.
Peut-être avons-nous des moeurs
politiques différentes.
Vous m'interrogez comme ministre
du Renouveau démocratique.
Nous sommes en 2023.
Nous ne sommes pas encore en 2026.
Notre préoccupation est de
répondre aux besoins quotidiens
des Français, pas de nous projeter
dans une élection qui aura lieu
dans 4 ans.
La préoccupation de ce
gouvernement n'est pas de savoir
s'il faudrait trancher la question
du nombre de mandats
présidentiels, mais de répondre
aux attentes du quotidien: la
sécurité, l'écologie...
Il faut qu'en 2027, les Français
ne soient pas tentés par un vote
populiste.
Ca doit vous parler.
Vous faites partie de ceux qui
l'incarnent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Une réponse,
madame la députée?
- Catherine Couturier: Vous
préférez combattre celles et ceux
qui agissent pour préserver notre
démocratie et notre liberté de
mouvement plutôt que celles et
ceux qui prônent le racisme et la
xénophobie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Daniel Grenon.
- Daniel Grenon: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres, mes chers collègues, à
monsieur le ministre de
l'Agriculture.
La peur du loup est une peur
ancestrale de l'homme.
L'homme a mis des siècles à se
débarrasser du loup.
En France, ce n'est que dans les
années 30 que le loup a enfin
disparu.
C'était avant l'apparition des
écologistes.
Depuis 1979, le loup bénéficie
d'un statut de protection absolue.
Statut que, récemment, la France
n'a pas voulu remettre en cause.
Au nom de la conservation de la
vie sauvage, le loup a été
réintroduit en France, y compris
des races qui n'ont jamais peuplé
la France.
Le danger est présent.
Ils se sont multipliés dans 50
départements français.
Ils ont causé plus de 4500
attaques en 2022.
Il y a quelques semaines, ils se
sont attaqués à un taureau de plus
d'une tonne.
Malgré clôtures et chiens, les
mesures prises dans le cadre du
plan loup sont insuffisantes.
Certains préfets autorisent les
tirs de défense.
Les décisions préfectorales sont
contestées par des associations et
le plus souvent invalidées par les
tribunaux.
Même les tirs d'effarouchement non
létaux peuvent être interdits, au
motif qu'ils peuvent perturber la
gestation des louves.
A terme, la disparition de
l'alimentation carnée est visée,
au profit de la viande
artificielle en laboratoire.
Nos éleveurs ne défendent pas
seulement leur gagne-pain, ils
aiment leurs animaux et demandent
la conservation de leur mode de
vie, mais vivent avec la crainte
permanente d'une attaque.
Attendez-vous qu'une personne
humaine soit attaquée par un loup
pour que la protection de la vie
des éleveurs soit placée au-dessus
de celle des loups?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Bérangère
Couillard.
- Bérangère Couillard: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Monsieur le député, sachez que
nous mesurons pleinement la
détresse des éleveurs français
face aux attaques des loups.
Nous sommes pleinement mobilisés
avec Marc Fesneau pour trouver les
solutions les plus pertinentes et
adaptées pour y faire face.
Le loup est une espèce strictement
protégée, revenue naturellement
depuis l'Italie en 1992.
Notre priorité, avec Marc Fesneau,
est d'assurer nos engagements de
protection, tout en permettant le
pastoralisme d'exercer son
activité.
Nous avons adopté en 2018 un plan
d'action avec la mise en place de
mesures de protection des
troupeaux.
Je pense au gardiennage par les
bergers à grande échelle, aux
achats de clôtures et aux chiens
de protection.
Vous avez beaucoup évoqué la
politique de tirs dérogatoires.
En 2022, 169 ont été prélevés sur
un plafond de 174 loups autorisés.
Ca correspond à la limite des 19%
de la population estimée.
58 loups ont été tués déjà, cette
année.
Nous ne devons pas réguler le
loup, mais les attaques sur les
troupeaux.
Le gouvernement a lancé
l'élaboration du futur plan
national d'action pour la période
2024-2029, qui est basé sur une
concertation.
Nous souhaitons des mesures
toujours plus efficaces.
Nous allons échanger avec les
organisations professionnelles
agricoles, les associations de
protection de l'environnement.
Nous souhaitons que ce travail
aboutisse à des solutions
équilibrées.
Nous ne voulons pas opposer ces
enjeux.
Nous voulons simplifier la vie des
éleveurs dont nous connaissons les
attentes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Une réponse,
monsieur le député?
- Daniel Grenon: Dans les années
30, c'était 40 millions
d'habitants qui peuplaient le
territoire.
Aujourd'hui, c'est près de 70
millions.
Reste-t-il assez de place pour les
loups?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Stéphanie Kochert
pour le groupe Horizons.
- Stéphanie Kochert: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à la
ministre chargée de la Ruralité.
Madame la ministre, plus de 30% de
nos concitoyens, 22 millions de
Français et de Françaises,
habitent en territoire rural.
Confrontés à des problématiques
spécifiques en matière d'accès aux
soins, aux services publics et aux
commerces de proximité, les
habitants de la ruralité, parfois
qualifiée de "France
périphérique", ont trop longtemps
été les oubliés de nos politiques
publiques, créant un sentiment
d'abandon et de déclassement.
Depuis 2017, une politique
volontariste a été menée en faveur
de la ruralité par le maintien des
dotations de fonctionnement.
Par la revitalisation des
centres-villes et centre-bourgs
avec les programmes Action coeur
de ville ou bien encore grâce au
désenclavement grâce à
l'installation de la 4g et de la
fibre.
Ces dispositifs passent aussi par
la création de maisons France
Services pour que le service
public investisse le territoire.
Je salue à ce titre le travail
conduit sur ce sujet par ma
collègue.
Par toutes ces mesures qui font
l'agenda rural comme par le plan
France Ruralités que vous avez
annoncé la semaine dernière, nous
faisons de la ruralité une
priorité de notre action.
Cependant, des inquiétudes
demeurent sur le terrain.
Nous avons déjà déployé un fonds
de 90 millions d'euros sur trois
ans pour développer une offre de
mobilité durable, innovante et
solidaire, dite du "dernier
kilomètre".
Comment s'assurer que nos plus
petites communes puissent se
saisir de ce fonds pour déployer
facilement des solutions
alternatives de mobilité?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Dominique Faure,
ministre déléguée chargée des
Collectivités territoriales et de
la Ruralité.
- Dominique Faure: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée Kochert, en
fait, vous appuyez tous vos propos
sur un sentiment de relégation et
d'abandon dans nos ruralités.
C'est une réalité.
Je la partage.
C'est pour ça qu'au terme de cet
agenda rural et de ces
investissements, nous avons pris
le sujet à bras-le-corps.
Effectivement, les ruralités sont
au coeur de nos politiques
publiques.
Vous citez trois points sur
lesquels je rebondis.
Ce sont 2750 maisons France
Services qui font qu'aujourd'hui,
moins de 30 minutes de trajet
séparent les habitants de ces
maisons.
C'est 2500 euros de plus, 5000
euros de plus en fonction des
zones de revitalisation rurale qui
seront déployés.
Vous citez aussi
l'ingénierie.
Je veux dire à quel point ce sera
partenarial.
Nous allons accompagner nos maires
sur leurs projets de village.
Vous nous demandez comment faire
sur les mobilités.
Les 30 millions d'euros vont agir
à la maille intercommunale.
Ce sont des autorités
organisatrices de la mobilité, en
complément des régions, qui vont
agir.
Nous avons aussi beaucoup
d'acteurs.
Je veux citer France Ruralités qui
porte les mobilités solidaires.
Ce sont toutes ces associations et
mairies qui vont déployer des
mobilités du dernier kilomètre.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Stéphane Viry.
- Stéphane Viry: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, au
1er juillet prochain, les tarifs
de vente de gaz réglementés vont
prendre fin pour les particuliers.
Si la disparition de ce dispositif
était prévue dans la loi énergie &
climat, le contexte inflationniste
impose des mesures pour protéger
le pouvoir d'achat des Français et
limiter les hausses.
Concrètement, 3 millions de foyers
vont changer d'offre alors que les
prix de l'énergie explosent en
Europe du fait de la reprise
économique mondiale, de notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles
ou de la guerre en Ukraine.
La fin des tarifs réglementés
risque de pénaliser davantage les
Français qui disposent d'une
chaudière à gaz pour se chauffer
et qui n'ont pas forcément les
moyens de s'équiper en pompes à
chaleur.
Le prix du gaz sera soumis à des
mouvements spéculatifs l'année
prochaine.
Cela va invariablement engendrer
une hausse incontrôlable des prix.
La hausse des prix alimentaires a
atteint des prix records en un an.
La liste est longue.
L'électricité a augmenté de plus
de 15% pour les particuliers.
Les carburants ont eux aussi
augmenté et ont atteint des
nouveaux records pendant de
nombreux mois.
Les dépenses contraintes des
ménages sont de plus en plus
élevées.
C'est le quotidien de nombreux
Français.
De nombreux Français ne s'en
sortent plus, alors même qu'ils
travaillent et qu'ils gèrent leur
budget.
Ma question est simple: comment
protéger ces Français déjà
lourdement touchés par une
inflation record et menacés par la
fin annoncée du bouclier
tarifaire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivia Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député, je vous prie
d'excuser l'absence de ma collègue
ministre de l'Energie.
Je porte la réponse en son nom.
Conformément à la loi, les tarifs
réglementés n'existeront plus pour
les particuliers et les
copropriétés.
80% des ménages sont sur des
offres non réglementées.
Il faudra basculer pour les autres
ménages vers des offres non
réglementées.
C'est déjà engagé depuis des
années, pour les consommateurs
professionnels comme pour les PME.
Ca s'est fait dans de bonnes
conditions.
Ce sera sans impact sur les
factures.
Les particuliers qui sont encore
au gaz peuvent choisir leur
contrat chez Engie ou un autre
concurrent.
Le bouclier tarifaire concerne
tous les consommateurs.
C'est important à rappeler.
Il faut limiter la hausse à 15% en
moyenne.
Ca a été une stratégie gagnante
qui nous a permis d'avoir
l'inflation la plus faible en
Europe cet hiver.
Bruno Le Maire l'a annoncé hier,
ce bouclier n'est plus nécessaire
pour le gaz, au regard des cours
actuels.
Nous assurons que les
consommateurs resteront très
informés.
C'est très important.
La Commission de régulation à
l'énergie va publier tous les mois
un prix de référence au regard des
prix sur les marchés européens.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Une réponse?
- Stéphane Viry: Je ne partage pas
votre optimisme.
Je crains de la prédation de la
part de certaines offres.
L'inflation n'existait pas, jadis.
La donne est différente,
désormais.
Les Français sont exposés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Céline Calvez.
- Céline Calvez: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la ministre des Sports et
des Jeux Olympiques et
Paralympiques, après de nombreux
mois d'incertitude sur la
diffusion en France de la
prochaine Coupe du Monde de foot
féminin, enfin une solution a été
trouvée la semaine dernière grâce
à votre impulsion.
Nous avons frôlé un recul dans
l'exposition médiatique du sport
féminin.
Heureusement, la diffusion sera
assurée par les groupes M6 et
France Télévisions.
Pouvez-vous nous donner les
détails de cet accord?
Cet accord sur la Coupe du Monde
de foot féminin, nous pouvons nous
en réjouir.
Force est de constater que de
nombreux efforts restent à
effectuer afin de renforcer la
visibilité du sport féminin au
sein de notre pays.
Une récente étude de l'Arcom le
révélait.
Moins de 30% des diffusions de
sport concernaient le sport
féminin en 2021.
Pourtant, il faut diffuser le
sport féminin.
Il faut encourager cette pratique.
Si les chaînes ont parfois pu
redouter le manque d'engouement
des téléspectateurs et
téléspectatrices, on doit noter
qu'il y a eu d'énormes succès
d'audience, que ce soit ceux et
celles de la Coupe du Monde de
football féminine en 2019 ou en
avril dernier, lors du Tournoi des
Six Nations féminin.
Comment le gouvernement agit pour
valoriser la diffusion du sport
féminin en France?
Qu'en est-il de l'intégration des
compétitions féminines
au sein du décret EIM qui protège
la diffusion d'événements
d'importance majeure?
Y aura-t-il des mises à jour de ce
décret pour plus de visibilité du
sport féminin sur nos télés?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Amélie
Oudéa-Castéra, ministre des
Sports.
- Amélie Oudéa-Castéra: Merci,
madame la présidente.
On est en effet soulagés et
heureux de cet accord.
On est soulagés, car notre équipe
de France féminine talentueuse,
unie et plus motivée que jamais va
pouvoir être diffusée cet été pour
cette compétition féminine de la
Coupe du Monde FIFA en Australie
et Nouvelle-Zélande.
Elles se préparent.
Elles sont dans leur rassemblement
aux côtés d'Hervé Renard.
On est heureux et soulagés.
Il y a une collaboration entre
deux groupes de l'audiovisuel,
privé et public, M6 et France
Télévisions.
On est heureux, car la FIFA a su
faire un bon pas dans cette
direction, en reconnaissant la
qualité de l'offre financière qui
était proposée et la qualité de
l'exposition qui allait être celle
de cette compétition.
L'Europe a su montrer son utilité.
Rima Adbul Malak avait mandaté
l'Union Européenne des radios
télédiffuseurs pour négocier, pour
qu'on ait plus de leviers.
J'avais mobilisé mes homologues
européens pour qu'on allie nos
énergies.
Cet accord se fait avec la
Fédération française de foot et en
complémentarité avec le groupe
Canal+ pour le championnat.
Nous progressons et on va
continuer, pas seulement pour le
foot féminin, mais aussi pour le
rugby, le volley-ball et le
basket.
Hier soir, on avait ce match
France-Grèce.
L'équipe de France masculine
portait le maillot de l'équipe de
France féminine.
Quand je vois ça, je me dis que
pour le sport féminin, dans le
foot en France aujourd'hui, on est
vraiment en train de changer
d'époque.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Frédéric Maillot.
- Frédéric Maillot: Merci.
Cela fait un an que nous portons
la voix de nos concitoyens
ultramarins.
C'est un an de luttes et d'alertes
sur la précarité qui touche les
peuples d'outre-mer.
C'est 365 jours d'alerte non-stop
sur une situation devenue
intolérable.
Cela fait un an que nous alertons
sur le coût de la vie sur nos
territoires.
Tout est cher: manger, se déplacer
et s'amuser.
Tout cela devant l'Etat qui est
complice des grandes industries,
qui tenaient le fouet durant
l'esclavage.
Cela fait un an que nous crions le
désespoir de nos frères et de nos
soeurs qui veulent rentrer
travailler au pays.
Nous attirons votre attention
depuis un an.
Que feriez-vous si cette situation
était la même en France
hexagonale?
Les outre-mer sont toujours les
grands oubliés de vos projets de
loi.
Nous sommes toujours à la
périphérie de vos décisions.
Madame et messieurs les ministres,
vos vagues promesses ne font pas
une politique.
Comment et quand allez-vous
réellement considérer les 2,2
millions d'hommes et de femmes
ultramarins que nous sommes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Jean-François
Carenco.
- Jean-François Carenco: Madame la
présidente, monsieur le député,
évidemment, je connais votre
discours.
Vous connaissez ma réponse.
Jamais, depuis longtemps, aucun
gouvernement n'a agi autant.
C'est comme ça.
Des dispositions spécifiques ont
été adoptées dès 2022.
Plafonnement des loyers, aide
alimentaire, etc.
Le PLF 2023 a fait la part belle
aux outre-mer.
Le rapport entre la population et
le budget est clair.
Les outre-mer sont au coeur des
soucis de ce gouvernement.
Des mesures spécifiques ont été
adoptées.
La loi relative à l'accélération
de la production d'énergie
renouvelable prévoit des
adaptations ultramarines.
La loi de programmation militaire
donne une place centrale aux
territoires ultramarins.
C'est en outre-mer qu'il y a le
plus beau taux de création
d'emplois.
C'est en outre-mer que le taux
d'inflation est le plus faible.
C'est en outre-mer que nous
travaillons le plus pour aider les
plus démunis.
Nous pouvons aller plus loin.
C'est le sens du prochain comité
interministériel de l'outre-mer
que la Première ministre présidera
le 6 juillet.
Vous connaissez le contenu que je
proposerai à la Première ministre.
Vous ne pouvez pas dire cela comme
ça.
L'ensemble des efforts sont faits.
C'est éminemment difficile.
Tout n'est pas législatif.
Les outre-mer ont aussi besoin de
respirer.
C'est le sens des dynamiques de
dialogue et de coconstruction que
nous menons.
Le gouvernement va continuer à
agir.
Ce n'est pas facile, mais vous le
savez.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Sébastien
Peytavie.
- Sébastien Peytavie: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Monsieur le ministre, mes chers
collègues, je voudrais vous
alerter sur le calvaire que vit
depuis 7 ans une femme atteinte
d'hémiplégie.
Elle survit dans un logement
social qui n'est pas accessible
aux personnes en situation de
handicap, contrairement à ce
qu'affirme son bailleur.
Elle est contrainte de ramper pour
accéder à sa douche et de
s'élancer depuis son fauteuil pour
rejoindre son lit, ce qui a déjà
provoqué plusieurs chutes et
blessures.
Désespérée face au silence des
pouvoirs publics, au refus répété
de son bailleur de la reloger dans
un logement accessible, cette
femme a commencé une grève de la
faim.
Je m'interroge.
De quelle dignité parlons-nous
lorsque la locataire est forcée de
ramper pour prendre une douche?
Cette situation que vit cette
femme est inacceptable et n'est
pas isolée.
L'Etat faillit chaque jour avec
les 12 millions de personnes en
situation de handicap dans notre
pays.
L'Etat faillit quand des enfants
en situation de handicap se
retrouvent sans école, faute
d'AESH.
Je voudrais rappeler que
l'accessibilité n'est ni une
faveur, ni une option.
C'est un droit fondamental et une
condition d'égalité entre toutes
et tous.
Ma question est la suivante.
Comment peut-on en arriver à une
telle humiliation?
Pourquoi n'y a-t-il aucun contrôle
sur les logements?
Que comptez-vous faire pour donner
une réponse rapide à cette femme
et à toutes les personnes en
situation de handicap à qui on
refuse un logement accessible?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivier Klein.
- Olivier Klein: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député, permettez-moi,
si vous en êtes d'accord, de ne
pas vous répondre sur le cas
particulier de la dame dont vous
faites état, dont nous connaissons
la situation.
Nous la suivons de manière
attentive.
Je tiens à votre disposition
l'ensemble des éléments.
Nous cherchons une nouvelle
solution pour cette personne car
il y a déjà eu des évolutions dans
son parcours résidentiel.
Néanmoins, je vais élargir ma
réponse.
Lors de la conférence nationale du
handicap, qui a été évoquée lors
de cette séance de questions au
gouvernement, le président de la
République a rappelé notre
ambition de faire de
l'accessibilité une priorité
nationale.
Nos concitoyens en situation de
handicap doivent pouvoir accéder
aux mêmes droits et participer
pleinement à la vie publique.
Le logement fait partie bien
évidemment de cet objectif
d'accessibilité universel.
Nous avons fait plusieurs annonces
récemment.
MaPrimeAdapt' sera ouverte à
l'ensemble des personnes en
situation de handicap, sans
condition d'âge.
Cet accompagnement financier, que
le logement soit privé ou social,
sera important.
Nous allons tout faire pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de mauvaises surprises
lors de l'attribution d'un
logement.
C'est l'objectif de cette
cartographie que nous allons
mettre en oeuvre.
Enfin, la loi 3DS a permis à des
personnes de trouver un logement
adapté à leur situation de
handicap.
Nous sommes très mobilisés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La séance est suspendue.